brown baby a new book by the author
nikesh shukla
is addressed to a child his
five-year-old daughter
it discusses the world into which she is
a mixed-race girl is growing up
and the challenges she will face very
pleased to say uh nikesh
joins us on the programme this morning
great to have you on nikesh um
tell us a little bit about the book
brown baby it's described as a
as a love letter to to your daughter but
also
to your mother who i understand you lost
just just days after your first book
was published tell us about the book
yeah
so brown baby is a memoir and a
manifesto it's kind of
about me trying to explore how to raise
my
kids to be joyful and boundless but also
realistic about the world
in a world that feels quite bleak and
one that i feel very
sad and angry about it you know it's
basically about all of the stuff that
keeps me up at night as a parent you
know staring up at the
shadows on the ceiling thinking well how
do i
talk to my kid about racism how do i
talk to my kid about
the patriarchy and misogyny how do i
explain to her about
climate catastrophe and that you know
these are probably all things that
a lot of parents are thinking about and
um
while my parenting journey hasn't been
like particularly out of the ordinary or
spectacular i felt like
discussions around these things were
things that i was doing a lot so i
thought putting them into
the memoir would be a good way of um
sharing those anxieties with people who
are also going through them
but also in writing them i realized that
um
my there was just an absence uh my mom
as
as as you said she died quite suddenly
just before um
my my first novel came out and like 10
years ago it was very sudden it was it
was a real shock to our family and
just that absence i i felt it so much
more than i
ever thought i would do when my kids
were born because
she just wasn't there and so part of the
memoir became about
trying to um reconcile myself with my
mum's passing
um nickish i mean a lot of the problems
that you you can raise or the concerns
that you have you know
i have as well about my child but of
course i'm not viewing them through
a mixed race lens i i wonder how the
experiences of
of your gujarati mother who frankly
sounds an absolute character from what
i've read
uh how the experiences that that she
herself had and that you recount in the
book
how they will be of of note and of worth
to to
to others in a similar situation yeah
definitely but you know just to kind of
stress that
um you know our lenses may be different
but the fact that these are things that
we're both thinking about i think
you know bears bear some highlighting
you know the book is called brown baby
because it is about the specificity of
raising
um a mixed-race child who will you know
be
racialized as as brown or mixed-race for
for the rest of her life
um uh but also these are things as you
said we should all be thinking about
you know my mum was my mum was she was
the one who taught me about the value of
community like i'm
i'm a really strong believer in
community and um
doing community service you know it's
why i do so much
work around sort of diversity and
inclusion in publishing as well as doing
all the writing stuff
and a lot of that is because of you know
what she instilled in me is important
she
she always instilled in me this this
feeling that there was a journey
higher than my own there was a there was
a purpose greater than my own needs that
i needed to
give myself to and and without her i
probably
uh wouldn't have wouldn't have um
thought about things in that way
um that question we're about to run out
of time but just just a word from you
about you know how your children have
viewed recent events
of course black lives matter george
floyd i mean have you been able to kind
of broach those
topics with with two young people
yeah definitely so we we live in bristol
so not far from where the colston statue
was uh brought down and my kid goes to a
school that um has an association with
colston and so
the school has been really wonderful at
talking to the
students about colston and about um
what he did and so we've been having
loads of really interesting
conversations and what i found actually
is that
my daughter wanted to know about the
bristol bus boycotts because they were
learning about them in school and
i started to explain them to her and as
i was explaining to her i realized that
i had to explain to her what racism was
and um in so doing i you know i tried to
explain it you know but erase it in a
way that she would understand you know
racism is something that
you know where people hate other people
because of the color of their skin and
obviously i know it's more complicated
than that
but um but she she she was
she was like well this is a stupid thing
i don't understand it this is
a preposterous concept and i started to
you know
put all my cynicism and jadedness and
world weariness onto
the conversation i realized that
actually no i needed to see the world
through her eyes and
as far as she was concerned yes it is a
preposterous thing and
that's how i need to talk to her about
it nikesh i'm so sorry for for rushing
us to the end we are just out of time
great to chat to you this morning and
don't worry buy the boat buy the boat
buy the book buy the book
maybe what you said nikki thanks very
much indeed